please explain what the boy defect is a
very common phenomenon in auto supply
change what it is about is the
amplification and a distortion of demand
information so as you observe in the
market where the man can fluctuate a
small bit but as every player in the
supply chain makes decisions based on
forecasting inventory control
speculations all those interactions
without it in demand for cars and orders
being amplified so as you go up the
supply chain you see much bigger swings
in orders compared with the market and
why are they calling this the bullwhip
effect well here is a graphical
depiction of whatever with this here I'm
holding a bullwhip and it should see the
bullwhip is a long long term and as I
crack the whip watch out for my handle
so the handle has only moved 60 degrees
while the tip of the whip has moved more
than 360 degrees and there's exactly
what happened the market may have moved
a tiny bit that is it the demand
information traveled up the supply chain
your upstream suppliers may be seeing a
much much bigger swing and that is
costly and that makes life difficult for
your suppliers because as this portion
happens so much bigger in magnitude it
makes it difficult for you to plan
production plan inventory capacity
planning transportation planning and
it's more costly as a result
can you talk about what you contributed
to broadening the field to a kind of a
broader holistic perspective in the
early days most people look at supply
chain as if this is about logistics is
about trucking about ships and
transportation warehousing but I think
today as a result of all these years of
research efforts by myself as well as my
colleague we have expanded supply chain
to includes channel marketing
information integration product design
design of processes accounting systems
economics in terms of incentives and so
this broadening of disciplines resulted
in supply chain being a
multidisciplinary research area
you